foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
they must be migrating migration what a
stupid idea okay you're impossible
because I found a safe place for us to
live
I want us to
be the world
[Music]
Wisconsin a Caribbean vacation I don't
want to miss out in life because you're
afraid to leave this pond
[Music]
hey
why are we the only Birds heading this
way
I promised adventure and this is exactly
what I promised
I stuck
if you with the range on top
you're old enough to do it in the sky
now we have a number two situation oh
but it's gross every bird does it in the
sky
no one
no one tells you we are not Landing
there is no way we're Landing
Wayne Mallard do it now or we leave
without you okay okay
you're completely lost we're trying to
get to Jamaica and I love birds it's
this way well we are not flying through
this crazy death trap of a city just
stay close to me and everything will be
all right
I'm okay yeah no I'm okay we can do this
maybe you don't stick too close
people
[Music]